I see. Let's move on to the first
category, the physical benefits. What
exactly are the physical benefits of
fasting?
Since fasting mainly involves in
abstaining from food, drink and sex from
dawn up to sunset.
Have we realized that the stomach is the
main organ of the body which has the
maximum diseases, maximum ailments?
That's why beloved prophet wasallam said
it's mentioned in Maja volume number
four had number 3349. Our beloved
prophet said
that there is nothing better that a son
of Adam can fill
in the container with more evils than
the stomach. It is sufficient for a man
to be on his feet with a few muscles.
But if he has to eat more, he can divide
the stomach into three parts. 1/3 for
the food, one/3 for the drink and one/3
for his breath or one third for the air.
So what we realize that the maximum
diseases originate in the stomach
because it's house for bacteria
and
the food that we eat it enters the
stomach from the stomach it gets
digested goes into the intestinal tract
then the food nutrients enter the
bloodstream and then goes to almost all
the different organs of the body and we
realize that the stomach is working
continuously throughout the life it
never gets any rest
when we fast. This stomach which is a
very delicate organ though it's very
delicate it is a very complicated organ.
It's delicate at the same time it's very
important it keeps on working throughout
the day. This organ while we fast when
no food enters for several hours it gets
rest
and the toxins that are there in the
body they are removed they are purged
out. So fasting is a very good way that
physically it's beneficial for the body.
It removes all the toxins and it helps
in various diseases.
What about the psychological impacts
upon the human psyche
regarding fasting? I think that's very
important.
>> As far as the psychological dimension is
concerned, fasting helps in patience,
forbearance and perseverance.
It helps a person to increase his
self-control,
his
self-worth.
It helps him to increase the
self-reflexivity.
Also, the self-training and discipline
is improved.
The main psychological benefit of
fasting is the increase in patience and
perseverance.
And it can make a person who says I
cannot do it can make him say I can do.
And fasting helps in the conditioning of
the heart, body, mind and soul. It
improves the overall dimension
of the human being.
And fasting is a sort of training. It
even helps in behavioral change. And
changing a behavior is very difficult. a
person who's used to a particular
behavior to change a person's behavior
very difficult. It is as we say that the
best type of jihad is jihad enough
that is striving against your own soul.
So to change the habits is one of the
thing which is most difficult which
fasting can do. And since jihad that is
going in the battlefield is of utmost
important when required. If you cannot
do jihad, if you cannot strive against
your own soul, how can you strive
against the enemy? So therefore fasting
helps in that dimension. That's the
reason fasting was made fur before
jihad. Fasting was made fur 15 years
after prophet in the second hij and next
year one year later jihad was made
first. So Allah subhanaa tala first
wanted to train and make the Muslims fit
psychologically
with the help of fasting and then the
part was made first. So psychologically
it's very helpful and normally a human
being he eats three meals in a day in a
week about 21 meals. Now that is changed
that behavioral pattern of feeding is
changed to two meals light meal late in
the evening early night and before dawn.
So the whole pattern is changed and this
helps in various psychological aspects
the training and today's psychology tell
us that if you can control your hunger
you can control almost all your desires.
actually from the psychological aspect
myself just to add something there um it
was the fasting in the last week and a
half of Ramadan which changed it for me
it changed my mind totally alhamdulillah
and that's what actually led me to
taking the shahada Alhamdulillah.